>> Mike: I GILDED HELICOPTERS
ARE ADORNING TREES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AS THE 2019 WHITE HOUSE
HISTORICAL ASSOCIATION'S
CHRISTMAS ORNAMENT.
DAVID'S FONT HAS THE CONCEPT
HANGING ON THE TREE.
>> THIS PRODUCTION LINE IS
HUMMING AS DOZENS OF EMPLOYEES
WORK LONG HOURS TO MAKE THIS
YEAR'S WHITE HOUSE CHRISTMAS
ORNAMENT.
>> IT'S EXCITING TO SEE WHAT YOU
CAN ACCOMPLISH.
>> DAVID MAKI IS THE PRESIDENT
OF A SECOND GENERATION OWN
FAMILY BUSINESS IN RHODE ISLAND.
THEY BEGAN PRODUCING WHITE HOUSE
THEMED ORNAMENTS IN 1951 AT THE
REQUEST OF NANCY REAGAN.
THIS YEAR THEY ARE APPROACHING
1 MILLION AND COME UP WITH
TOGETHER BY HAND.
>> THEY PUT IT TOGETHER USING A
TAB IN SLOT SYSTEM THAT THEY'VE
DEVELOPED WITH A PAIR OF PLIERS.
>> THEY PAY TRIBUTE TO THE
PRESIDENTS IN SEQUENTIAL ORDER.
THE FIRST ORNAMENT HONORED
GEORGE WASHINGTON, AND THE 2008
BENJAMIN HARRISON ORNAMENT MARKS
THE FIRST TRADITIONAL CHRISTMAS
TREE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
2019 ORNAMENT IS UNLIKE THE
REST.
AT THREE DIMENSIONAL HELICOPTER
ON THE WHITE HOUSE SOUTH LAWN.
>> EVERY YEAR IS EXCITING WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
BECAUSE IT REALLY PUSHED THAT
TECHNOLOGY TOWARDS IT.
>> IT'S A TRIBUTE TO
PRESIDENT NUMBER 34,
DWIGHT D. EISENHOWER.
>> HE WAS FIRST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TO USE A HELICOPTER
FOR PRESIDENTIAL TRAVEL.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
HISTORICAL -- YOU SEE THAT
MAJESTIC HELICOPTER FLY IN AND
LANDED ON THE SOFT LAWN ON THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT
AND THE FIRST FAMILY DISEMBARK,